that's actually a funny story so I was
actually really racist two times and
both times I was right were you racist
then I'm at my next door neighbor black
dude right six six kind of got a good
build I was like he's an athlete got his
name Google them right see it I knew he
played in the NBA and then two days ago
I was walking my dog saw some dude
backwards hat I'm not even gonna tell
you the skin color we already know he's
just he's on his knees pulling weeds out
which is so much swag that no other race
could move like that we talk a little
bit I Googled his name he's a ref for
the NBA no way so he has that like
basketball swag he's around it two times
racism two times right I think the
sample size of the times you were racist
and you were right I think it was real
small right now I bet there's way more
instances where you were like
potentially racist and that was wrong
and you were also right that's just
probably 100 out of 100. there's
probably like you're probably maybe a
thousands